hey how's everybody doing today I want
to remind everybody about the giveaway
that I'm doing that you might not have
heard if you didn't listen to my last
video I want to give one of you guys a
gift for Christmas for supporting the
channel in the videos and I'm going to
give away any season of Game of Thrones
on blu-ray that you choose all you need
to do is be a subscriber of this channel
to get an entry for the random selection
and I'm going to randomly select that
winner on January 1st and lets you pick
your favorite season of the show and
I'll send it to you right away
but I also want to say don't worry if
you don't win this time because as soon
as I send out that gift I'm going to do
another giveaway right after that so
don't unsubscribe just yet because you
have another chance to win something and
if you're already a subscriber you're
going to get two entries so keep that in
mind but anyways let's get the show on
the road I want to thank everybody for
their great answers this is going to be
another breakdown prediction video for
Game of Thrones season 7 and I couldn't
answer everyone's question but some of
the really good ones that I didn't get
to I'm going to save and do in another
video so if it doesn't get to yours I
want to thank you for the input I
definitely appreciate it now let's get
started and I want to start the video
off with arguably the greatest game of
Thrones theory you have ever heard this
theory was inspired by a loyal listener
sir Jaime Lannister he always leaves
some great comments and out of respect
for his sense of humor I had to do this
so brace yourself and put some tinfoil 1
because some spoilers are coming Jaime
Lannister said if I don't see a
prediction about me arming myself up
with a spanking brand-new bazooka cannon
for an arm you're in trouble
well sir Kingslayer here you go buddy
now we all know that Jaime Lannister had
his hand cut off a few seasons ago while
he was a prisoner of the Bolton men and
ever since then Jaime has just been a
shell of himself he has nearly lost all
confidence in himself especially when it
comes to fighting Jaime Lannister was
once known as one of the greatest
swordsman in Westeros but after he lost
his strong hand he can barely beat an
average soldier so out of desperation
and embarrassment Jaime was willing to
even take private lessons from bran
which didn't go too well I mean Bronn is
a pretty damn good swordsman but he
kicked Jaime's ass pretty easily Jaime
just really can't find a strength to put
up a good fight using his other hand but
thankfully for Jaime he doesn't really
have to fight
or himself too often but next season
that day is going to come to an end and
Jamie Lannister is going to have to do
everything it takes to ensure that the
Lannisters do not lose their stronghold
in King's Landing Jamie knows that a
massive war is coming in a big army
large enough to destroy King's Landing
as we know it and Cersei does not want
to lose this war
Cersei does not want to vacate the Iron
Throne and if there's one thing we know
about Jaime Lannister it's that he will
do just about anything for his sister
when she says jump Jaime says how high
and in season six Cersei made Jaime
leave the army just like their father
used to and even though the blackfish
gave Jaime some resistance in the end
Jaime was successful but Danny's now
coming for the Iron Throne and she isn't
going to be as easy not with her large
army and large dragons and no matter how
strong the Lannister army may be it
doesn't change the fact that Jaime only
has one hand and Jaime knows when a time
comes to fight Daenerys and her forces
he's going to have to get off his ass
and fight and Jaime knows that he is
going to need to fight very well or else
they will lose and him and his sister
will die and lose the Iron Throne until
Cersei losing is just unacceptable so
the theory basically is for Jaime to
please Cersei he's going to enlist the
help of Qyburn Jaime saw firsthand what
he was able to do with that freak of the
mountain so Jamie's going to go to
Qyburn and tell him there's a war coming
and I'm gonna need your help this golden
hand that you made me isn't doing [ __ ]
you're gonna have to get pretty creative
Cersei sent me off to conquer Highgarden
so I'm gonna need you to have something
for me when I get back because Daenerys
Targaryen is coming and she's bringing
the unsullied that a three and three
big-ass dragons so Cogburn he's
definitely going to get to work for
Jaime but Qyburn has no idea what Jaime
actually once and after Jaime and Bronn
get defeated by the Dothraki where Jaime
is nearly killed by one of Danny's
dragons Jaime's going to see firsthand
just how terrifying these dragons are
and knows he needs something very
powerful to defeat them but when Jaime
returns to Cersei he's going to be an
even broker man knowing that he let
someone
men's army defeat him in his Lannister
forces in the rest of what little
confidence he had left will be
completely stripped away from him but
Circe's heartless since he's not going
to care Cersei will now feel that the
walls are closing in on her knowing that
the mighty Jaime Lannister and his
forces were just defeated by Daenerys
Targaryen he was getting closer and
closer to attacking King's Landing sir
she's going to be so furious she's going
to tell Jaime you either kill this
bitch's dragons and send her back across
the Narrow Sea or I'm going to send your
ass to Castle black to live out the rest
of your pathetic one-handed days and
Jamie is going to be shocked by this the
thought of Cersei leaving him for good
is going to send shockwaves across
King's Landing
Jaime's going to run a Qyburn praying he
has devised something that can make him
victorious in battle again but
unfortunately for Jamie the first thing
Kai burns going to give him is widows
wail that is forged to a new golden hand
that way Jaime can never drop his sword
or have it knocked out of his hand again
but now Jamie's going to be furious and
screaming Qyburn this isn't good enough
Cersei threatened to send me to the wall
and the best you can come up with is a
[ __ ] sword not into my hand I thought
you was banned from being a maester
because of your odd methods in creative
ways
Jaime's going to tell Qyburn I'm going
to give you one day one [ __ ] day to
get me something better than this or I'm
going to take you to Castle black with
me and throw you off the top of that
goddamn wall now kabra is going to be
backed into a corner and he's going to
get the work right away everybody knows
that Qyburn works best under pressure
thankfully Khyber knows of a cave and
Dragonstone that is filled with
dragonglass and with the help of the
mountain and Jagan Hegar they're going
to take a small boat to Dragonstone at
night and even though Danny and her
forces are there Qyburn is going to be
able to convince them anyway jaqen
H'ghar is going to provide the faces of
dragons that way if Danny comes out
she's just going to think it's Drogo and
Rhaegar screwing around outside and the
mountains going to be used for a
strength to carry out one ton of
dragonglass which will be used to form
Jaime Lannister's new weapon a weapon so
powerful it can take down a dragon with
a single blow and after working 20
four hours straight Qyburn will send the
mountain to get Jaime Lannister to bring
him back to his workshop and I'm going
to guarantee you right now this scene
will be the most glorious moment of
season seven Qyburn is going to present
to Jaime a [ __ ] dragon glass cannon
with a built-in rotator cuff given Jaime
360 degrees of range cannon balls come
separately of course and there will be
an engraving on the side that says sir
[ __ ] hand cannon Jaime Lannister will
now have the greatest weapon ever
constructed in Westeros in equalizer so
feared dragons will smother their babies
rather than to see them shot out of the
sky that's right folks and what their
powers combined Jaime [ __ ] Lannister
will be known as Captain Planet [ __ ]
terror I challenge anyone to come up
with a better theory than what I am now
calling our plus l equals cannon let
that sink in for a little bit now let's
get on to the questions Shawn dub asked
do you think everything in a plug leak
is going to happen and my answer is no
but I think it is very likely that most
of it will happen so much evidence has
came out since the leak was released
that continues to support it and I think
if I was a lawyer and was given the plot
leaked and I had to prove it was fake in
court with all the reports and photos
that have came out as evidence I think I
would probably lose that case but with
that being said I highly doubt it's a
hundred percent accurate I think it is
possible that it is or excuse me it once
was a hundred percent accurate but I
would hope that Dan and Dave would have
made some necessary changes but either
way some of the stuff in the leak just
doesn't sound very logical and most of
the stuff in the leak was pretty easy to
guess if you watch the show the show
lays out clues in each episode that can
give you a good idea of what's going to
happen next so I could easily see
someone predicting the majority of
season sevens plot but there were you
know too many things in that league that
was hard to predict like Jon Snow
teaming up with Jorah in the house and
the show hasn't really gave us any clues
to those guys specifically going north
of the wall together and now that photos
have came out showing these guys
together and Belfast at a set that is
supposed to stand in for a scene north
of the wall
it's obvious to me that this person got
a good better than sleek right but
definitely not all of it at least I hope
some of it is wrong so that's what I
think about that and David as do you
think the iron bank would turn our backs
on the Lannisters in demand payment for
the loans they made to Tywin who would
you think would ride Circe's dragons
after John and Danny and how would the
Nights Watch changed after the departure
of John Snow
alright so let me try and break some of
this down it said would the iron bank
turn our back on the Lannisters because
of their outstanding loans I say yes yes
they would I think eventually the iron
bank is going to have to do something to
see that they get paid we know the iron
bank would have no problem with funding
any of the Lannisters enemies if it
comes to that point but I'm just not
sure you know if the show is going to go
into it that much because they've barely
showed the iron bank they really don't
seem like that big of a threat in the
show but that's something they could add
to make things interesting and give the
Lannisters another enemy or at least
another thing to worry about just add
some more drama to the show and I can
easily see the Lannister house being
completely destroyed by the end with
only Tyrion being left to carry on the
name which was the last thing Tywin
wanted but I think would actually be the
best thing for that family in my opinion
in speaking to Tyrion you asked about
the dragons and who would ride them
other than John and Danny you said they
are Circe's dragons but I'm assuming you
meant Danny's dragons but Tyrion would
be the only other person I could see
riding a dragon unless you want to count
the night's king which I guess is always
possible but Tyrion is the only person
besides Dany that has any kind of bond
with the Dragons they seem to you know
warm up to him and accept Tyrion when he
went down and Unchained him so he would
be my first guess but you know it's hard
to say it seems like there's a theory
out there that everybody's a Targaryen
so I really don't know but I bet my
money on Tyrion but next one cutie Jen
asked how do you think John will find
out about his parents with everything
happening do you think he will have a
chance to reunite with brain and Aria
had Winterfell well I think John will
absolutely find out about his parents
next season I think it will be at the
very end of season 7 I think there are
several different ways John can find
out though and if I had to bet money on
which way I think he finds out I would
bet bran is the one to show him or tell
him about his parents the show already
took the time and spent the money on the
scene to show us that brain is the one
to find out about John's parents first
so I think bran will be the one to tell
John eventually but I think John's going
to leave Winterfell for Dragonstone
before bran and Arya get there though so
he's just going to miss them but at the
end of the season I think he will make
it back to Winterfell for the big
reunion with his family and there was a
chance John could find out about his
parents on his own too John may be the
one to take Rick on down into the crypts
and I think there's a very good chance
something's down there that points to
who his parents are and Ned may have
even made John his own space down there
and put his real name on a statue and
many people also think Rhaegar hork
could be down there as well what all
these things are possible and Howland
Reed could you know also inform John too
because we know bran and mirror headed
back home and bran should tell mirror
that he saw her father in a vision
during the birth of John and he could
tell mirror to have her father come to
Winterfell to confirm it for John since
they showed us Howland Reed once I think
we could see him again
either way John we'll find out who his
real parents are then personally I can't
wait and sube was one of many people
that asked if I think bran will try and
save tyene sand now that she was taken
prisoner and she's about to be in the
hands of Cersei Lannister but my answer
is no bran will not save her I think
just because she flirted with bran that
does not mean he's going to get in
Circe's way of vengeance I don't think
there's no chance in hell
bran really doesn't give a [ __ ] about
her and he really didn't give a [ __ ]
about the last woman that he was
actually supposed to marry you know once
there's money involved all bets are off
with bran he's only concerned with
himself which he made very clear to
Tyrion when Tyrion wanted his help you
know during the trial by combat bran
didn't risk his life there and I don't
think he's going to risk his life here
Cersei is not going to hand over a
prisoner just because bran wants to get
some [ __ ]
I think tyene sand is a dead woman
walking sorry but I don't think she's
going to leave Circe's grasp or King's
Landing
live that's just my opinion now and
Scott asked if Theon does intend to
rescue Yara who do you think will
accompany him any other major characters
or just the on in the Ironborn he
arrived with maybe the Ironborn and John
twist the ons arm to force him to go
save Yara now this is a great question
because I certainly believe fee on will
go save Yara but I'm still having
trouble deciding who would go with him I
think he could easily go with a team of
Ironborn men but I also feel like
Daenerys could send him with some of her
men maybe some of the unsullied or
Dothraki just a small team know to get
in and out quickly without starting a
war prematurely and I don't really think
John would go I don't see John risking
his life for Theon at this point but I
could see John maybe lending him some
wildlings to go with him if need be but
John only arrived at Dragonstone with a
few men so I'm not sure if he would send
any of those guys with him because I
think those guys are actually stark
bannermen but if I had to bet I would
say the Ironborn men would be the first
to volunteer to go with Theon
but I think Danny may feel bad that she
was captured especially after how well
Danny and Yara hit it off so I could see
Danny being eager to get her back so I
could see her sending some of her men
for sure tell me what you guys think
though and DJ sherry asked is there any
more wildfire in King's Landing if any
more where is it it says a we know
Tyrion used some at the Battle of
Blackwater Bay to try and stop Stannis's
fleet and Cersei used some to destroy
the Sept of Baelor
if there is any more cancer sea use this
against Danny's fleet and I say yes
absolutely I think there is more
wildfire I think there's plenty of
wildfire left in King's Landing I think
it is still hitting underneath the city
streets placed all over the entire city
and I wouldn't be surprised if we
actually get a scene at some point that
shows Qyburn trying to make some more I
think Cersei could use it against
Daenerys fleet but I don't think she can
pull off the same trick that Tyrion did
Tyrion is with Dany and he is advising
her now so he should probably advise her
about the possibility of this happening
but there are some other way she could
do it I guess she could use some kind of
a catapult and make it rain fire down on
her
just like her dragons are doing other
people but of course we know the fire is
going to kill Danny so you know it
really doesn't matter to her but it
definitely could destroy her fleets it
significantly and kill a lot of her men
so yeah I think there is more wildfire
for sure and we will probably see it
again we may even need to use it against
the whites when the main war comes so
don't be surprised if we see that stuff
again I actually hope we do see it again
and mr. bean fan asked if we will
actually see John and Danny have sex
next season and if I would like it and
is it incest I think there's a very
strong chance we will see them get
together next season I don't think it's
going to happen on a boat like the leek
said but I can't see them getting
together the show has been building
towards this and Danny even mentioned to
dario about finding another man in
Westeros and John seems like the only
good person that's eligible right now I
think John and Danny would make a great
team especially when you combine their
strengths but I personally do not want
to see them have sex and that's only
because I know they're related I have no
problem seeing Danny naked you know
she's very easy on the eyes but I don't
need to see it and I know Targaryen I've
done this before and I know that says
normal in this time period but I don't
need to see it
it is technically incest because Danny
is Jon's aunt having sex with your anus
not cool even if she is beautiful but
can you imagine if John and Danny had a
kid those are two very big shadows to
live in but their kid good could grow up
to be one hell of a leader and this is
going to be my last one for the day
influenced by design asked would Sochi
and Iran become real lovers and anchor
Jamie in the process maybe driving him
to kill Cersei and I say absolutely if
Cersei and Euron get together
Jaime's not going to be happy which
could lead for some great television
finally the person Jaime has been
fighting for and killing for could
finally make one last decision that was
the straw that broke the camel's back
and drove Jaime to murder them both you
know you're on would be cocky as [ __ ]
about it too he probably grabbed Cersei
by the ass while he's staring right into
Jaime's eyes just to piss him off even
more Jaime would die before he would let
somebody else marry Cersei and sit in
his seat
I could never see Jamie sit on the
sidelines while Cersei rules with
another man
I think Jamie needs to leave regardless
and this could be the catalyst for Jamie
to do so I don't think Jamie and Euron
are going to get along at all
it's going to be very interesting to see
how this dynamic plays out when Euron
approaches them to form an alliance I'm
definitely looking forward to your own
storyline during season 7 I think Dan
and Dave have a real chance to make
urine into a great character on a show
and I really hope they do right before
they kill him off of course but I will
discuss more in another video I
appreciate everyone that participated I
will get to the other questions very
soon also guys don't forget about the
giveaway just subscribe for a chance to
win but uh thank you guys I appreciate
all the love and support and comment
below if you you know want to discuss
any of those stuff I'll see you guys in
the comment section bye